un énorme scoop people pour vous
aujourd'hui selon closer public france
dimanche et même babouche magazine un
couple mythique du petit écran et du
monde des people s'est reformé alors je
vous montrais des deux photos floutées
voilà bah ouais nan mais c'est tout et à
votre avis c'est petit et je rencontrais
ce week end donc des questions qu'est ce
qui s'est passé obama obama prend on a
déjà formé un couple ça va vous sinon
oui internationale non pas du tout passé
la cedh et les français ces français
s'est elle est une femme non toujours en
activité oui à lutry ce nom mais la
coupe est avec vous oui comédienne nom
centre le mythique maillot mythique we
meetic un mail ce allemand voire non une
femme j'ai acheté les non c'est pas
comme ça un homme alors à l'humoriste
fans humoriste et animateur est ce qu'il
vous doit beaucoup c'est vous avec anna
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
géraldine à une idée j'ai l'impression
cccc c'est-à-dire camille combal on
regarde la réponse oui je vais vous
raconter ce qui s'est passé j'étais
tranquillement dans la rue là où ça je
sors s'il vous plaît je sors et là
vraiment impossible voilà de se louper
on sort en même temps tous les deux
camille combal et moi on ne s'étaient
pas revus depuis assez longtemps
je l'avais au téléphone quand il avait
fait la première de danse avec les stars
après je vous cache pas c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu tendus avec la sphère
karine ferri karine ferri d'ailleurs
sais pas car elle ne s'est jamais son
prénom celle ci et on s'est vus et je
vous le dis savez comme qu'on savait
tous arrêtés comme dans une comédie
romantique savez comme quand coup de
foudre à nothing hill on est là on s'est
vus camille combal et moi et c'est vrai
qu'on sait on s'est embrassés ah c'est
beau et on s'est dit qu'on se manquait
on s'est dit qu'on sait mais voilà et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est vrai qu'on a
on est on s'écrit après tout ça on s'est
dit qu'on allait faire des petites
soirées ensemble ouais mais voilà il m'a
dit qu'il avait tourné de masse singer
la semaine dernière voilà oui on s'était
marié le seul petit truc qui l'avait
c'est qu'il était avec sa femme dans la
rue donc je vais dit écoute tu aurais pu
me l'annoncer avant mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'est revus et c'est vrai que ça
nous a fait du bien à tous les deux de
se revoir parce qu'il y avait eu ce
petit voilà c'était pas on n'était pas
fâché mais on s'est un petit peu tendues
depuis la faire karine ferri et c'est
vrai que tous les deux voilà on avait on
était ému voilà de se rencontrer de se
revoir
moi j'étais en tee shirt de tennis voilà
et je crois que je ne vais pas laisser
indifférent et donc voit dans serré que
ça et j'ai pris une décision
c'est vrai que on parle on parle souvent
des émissions de camille tout ça et
c'est vrai que j'ai du mal encore à
entendre voilà des trucs un peu sur
camille tout ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est on se dit on le dit tous les deux
on est on est comme deux frères et c'est
vrai que bon on a été un peu c'est
pareil comme ça voilà par par le destin
non voilà on sent sa princesse
énormément oui par tf1 par le destin
mais bon c'est très bien et c'est vrai
que j'ai du mal à parler de ses
émissions etc
voilà
donc j'ai pris une décision sans parlons
un peu de danse avec les stars
mais pour l'instant je ne veux pas quoi
le coup je n'ai pas envie voilà qu'on
fasse de jugement sur camille ou sur sa
me voilà ça me gêne c'est que la jolie
donc après voilà on fait tout ce qu'on
voulait voilà la mission voilà je
voulais vous le dire est ce que si ça
vous dérange vous me le dites non si ça
ne vous dérange pas vous me le dit aussi
voilà c'est vous le chef non pas du tout
mais non non vous vous ai jamais empêché
de parler de quelque chose c'est vrai
jamais voilà donc voilà donc voilà donc
mais c'est vrai que ça nous a fait du
bien de nous revoir et j'avais envie de
vous le raconter parce que je pense
qu'on va on va se revoir en plus je lui
ai dit qu'on allait certainement faire
un bowling ce milieu de semaine
prochaine
mais ce n'est pas une banale sa superbe
à gérer mais tu ça fait rêver
de manière globale quand on en avait
parlé il ya deux ans pour danse avec les
stars je crois que toute la race à part
peut-être gymkhana gilles mais je crois
que toute la bande on avait reconnu son
roi et son talent dans l'émission merci
en tout cas voilà donc je vous donnerai
des nouvelles et j'espère que peut-être
qu'un jour qui viendra nous voir dans
touche pas à mon poste
[Applaudissements]